[Music]
we all have our favorite Disney heroines
and while some belong in the traditional
Disney setting others challenge all
stereotypes that come with being a
princess the time has come to give them
all a brand new modern-day rebellious
look wait until you see what Moana would
actually look like as a rebel give this
video a thumbs up if you love Disney and
don't forget to subscribe to our Channel
let's check out ten Disney Princesses
reimagined of modern-day bad girls Ariel
let's start off with an easy one
although she's headstrong and full of
attitude Ariel is still one of the
sweetest Disney mermaids ever her
angelic face which is based on the looks
of Alyssa Milano is absolutely perfect
and it's hard to imagine Ariel would
look any different but we decided to
give her a bit of a makeover and show
her dark side too here she is Ariel as a
bad girl it looks like this Ariel got a
transformation during your time on the
lam
check out those awesome tribal tattoos
we expected something more ocean themed
but they still look pretty awesome don't
they she's of course having a bath and
taking a selfie with her pink phone
let's just hope she doesn't drop it in
the tub did you catch the Illuminati
tattoo on her hand did you know that
Ariel is actually related to the sytem
the god of the sea he's our grandfather
if you know a few stories about Poseidon
you know he can get pretty angry and me
so Ariel's bad girl transformation could
actually make sense Alyssa Milano has
tattoos herself although this version of
Ariel definitely wasn't inspired by her
what do you think could the sweet and
headstrong Ariel become a mermaid with
an attitude
she's been ranked as the 12th least
feminist Disney Princess although she's
definitely not as sweet as some of the
other princesses on our list Rapunzel
who can possibly forget about Rapunzel
one of the most beloved Disney
Princesses did you know Rapunzel was the
first Disney princess with superpowers
her title is usually forgotten but you
shouldn't forget about her magical hair
that made people feel young it's hard to
imagine her out of her element when her
greatest weapon was a frying pan she
definitely doesn't look like she could
be a bad girl even as a modern-day
princess does she well in our world
Rapunzel rebelled
and completely transform check her out
long nails purple snapback snazzy outfit
and platform shoes this rapunzel is
definitely ready to rock purple suits
are as does modern clothing that doesn't
involve typical Disney dresses we have a
feeling this version wouldn't be able to
stay in that tower for a long time and
she definitely wouldn't use a frying pan
as her choice of a weapon would he using
is this how you would have imagined
Rapunzel as a modern-day princess or do
you see her in any other way
speaking of Rapunzel do you know that
tangled was Disney's 50th film and the
crew didn't even realize it until they
were six months into the project they
also changed the storyline from passive
female characters to the awesome
long-haired princess that could do tons
of damage with her frying pin what would
be modern-day Rapunzel's choice of a
weapon Elsa
let it go let it go can't hold it back
anymore Elsa's appearance in frozen took
over the world and nobody expected it we
bet some of you are still singing the
lyrics to the famous let it go that got
stuck in our heads for months after
frozen first came out if Rapunzel is the
first Disney princess with magical
powers Elsa is definitely the second
Elsa is calm and graceful but in the
original script Elsa was supposed to be
a villain with that in mind we found
this illustration which belongs to
Adelaide chrome on deviantART who
illustrated what a dark version of Elsa
might have looked like it seems like
this Elsa drew lots of inspiration from
anime especially when it comes to her
hair we're totally digging the dark look
and we're in love with her dress this
also definitely wouldn't hide away
because she's too afraid of her powers
she probably kicked some serious butt
lism instead do you know that it took
Walt Disney's 70 years to perfectly
adapt the Snow Queen story he's been
trying to get it right since the 1930s
and it finally happened the original
Elsa and Anna weren't even related and
Elsa had blue hair similar to what you
see in this dark version the redesign of
the characters could have costs Disney
billions of dollars but instead frozen
became one of the most successful Disney
movies Jasmine when it comes to
headstrong characters who have
challenged the stereotypes of what a
normal Disney
should look like jasmine is definitely
the one we have to mention without her
Aladdin wouldn't be the same and we mean
literally he wouldn't be the same as a
character
Aladdin's illustrations had to be
changed after the animation team
illustrated Jasmine they realized her
character is far too graceful for a
Latin scruffy version we love Jasmine's
attitude and her wit but we're also
completely in love with her modern-day
Batgirl look this illustration belongs
to Josh WMC from deviantART who gave her
a complete makeover and turned Jasmin
into a warrior check her out if it
wasn't for her long dark hair and her
signature blue clothing you'd never even
know it's her she looks like she's ready
for a battle with this look we can
totally see her in a show like The Game
of Thrones it makes us wonder what would
a modern-day Aladdin look like he'd have
to be pretty strong and muscular to
match with this powerful version of
jasmine did you know that the original
storyline featured Aladdin's mother
which significantly lessened jasmine
screen time jasmine only played a
significant part after the team decided
to turn aladdin into an orphan it's hard
to imagine Aladdin would even work
without jasmine and we'd probably never
get this modern-day jasmine illustration
if it would bail along with some of the
latest versions of Disney Princesses
Belle was also the one that confronted
the typical stereotypes of what Disney
Princesses should look like although
she's far from ideal Belle showed signs
of a modern-day princess by enjoying
books and refusing to be with the most
attractive guy in town instead she chose
adventure and went with someone whose
heart was much more attractive than his
looks
if you don't think Belle was a good
representation of a modern-day Disney
Princess this illustration should change
your mind
it belongs to Joel Santana an artist
who's known for creating modern-day
Disney Princesses and giving them a new
perspective check out this awesome
illustration of a modern-day Belle
reading her book all while getting
tattooed by an artist that looks like
the Beast is by far one of the most
evocative illustrations we're showing
you today but it's also our favorite
speaking of Beauty and the Beast if you
haven't seen the 2017 live-action movie
adaptation you definitely should it's by
far the most modern-day Disney movie
ever and it even features LGBT
characters which of course raised a lot
of controversy with traditional Disney
fans however the storyline is
beautifully adapted to what Belle and
the rest of the characters
like in the modern-day snow white now
let's talk about the youngest Disney
Princess Snow White is still loved by
traditional Disney fans but often
criticized by those who believe a
modern-day princess should possess much
stronger character qualities Snow White
is gentle nice and caring and completely
different from any other Disney
Princesses his storyline was sweet and
simple but we'd love to see Snow White
in a completely different modern-day
version TLM from deviantART took the
opportunity and illustrated what Snow
White might look like in the modern
world as a possible villain here's a mug
shot
this Snow White got herself in a lot of
trouble and it seems like she doesn't
even care that much about the fact she's
in jail we adore her red and white dress
along with the iconic hairstyle that
really hasn't changed that much although
it's highly unlikely we'll ever see a
modern-day Snow White with this agenda
we have to admit this illustration is
highly entertaining do you think Snow
White could ever land or something jail
the original character is far too sweet
to ever get herself in any kind of
trouble do you know that Snow White's
sweet voice was so special Walt Disney
forbade the actress from performing for
any other movie she was locked down in
the contract which is why her
character's voice remains unique to this
day Cinderella
speaking of typical Disney Princesses
that didn't break out of their shell and
remain true to their traditional
characters Cinderella is also often
criticized for her lack of modern-day
agenda many have criticized the
storyline as it seems like Prince
Charming based his love on a simple shoe
size and Cinderella's dress at the ball
but there's something charming about
Cinderella and her story which is why we
think her modern-day adaptation would
actually be quite amazing johanna mosey
from deviantART showed off her skills
and illustrated her version of a
modern-day Batgirl Cinderella it's safe
to say this Cinderella looks completely
exhausted from being bossed around and
is probably hiding somewhere and trying
to relax we're having to deal with their
annoying stepmother and stepsisters we
are totally in love with this version of
her iconic blue dress however we bet
that's not how most envisioned a
modern-day Cinderella we have to admit
this is a pretty under taining
illustration it seems like this
Cinderella just came from her ball
judging by the glass slipper on the
floor Cinderella was already adapted
into a modern-day movie into that
tene did you know that in the 2015
version Cinderella wears eight versions
of her gown throughout the movie it took
four thousand hours to make all eight
versions and we bet it took two Anamosa
just as much to drop this amazing
picture Pocahontas speaking of
modern-day Disney Princesses many Disney
fans have praised Pocahontas for her
story and her character unlike many
other princesses Pocahontas is strong
and independent and she doesn't let
people like John Smith step all over
Pocahontas is storyline is far from
traditional which is exactly why it's
one of our favorites on top of that
she's absolutely gorgeous as is this
modern-day version that shows Pocahontas
in a slightly different light we
wouldn't change much about Pocahontas
but this version made her look even more
fierce and ready for action
the illustration belongs to Josh WMC
from deviantART who gave Pocahontas a
modern look and dressed her up in jeans
her outfit still remains true to her
culture but we're absolutely in love
without beard she looks her and jasmine
would make one of the best modern-day
Disney Princess hairs ever the
Pocahontas wasn't just praised for her
modern-day characteristics as a princess
the movie was also a first disney movie
that featured an interracial
relationship which was a huge step
forward for what this the character
itself was largely modeled by Irene the
guard who could easily model for his
modern-day Pocahontas illustration do
you think this version of Pocahontas
would put up with John Smith's terrible
misogynistic attitude or would her story
be completely different Moana and here
she is the top-ranked modern-day Disney
Princess that is challenged every single
storyline and became one of the lumati
is of modern generation Moana is
Disney's first-ever Polynesian princess
and also one of the few that doesn't
have a romantic agenda in the movie her
story is inspirational and it talks
about following your heart without
falling in love with any male characters
in the process
way to go Disney Kawana is already a
pretty advanced Disney Princess but we
thought we'd show you what she looked
like as a rebellious character check her
out we put her hair up and gave her a
pink headband and put her in typical
modern-day clothing she's also holding a
bag and if you look closely you can see
a tattoo on her leg the movie has been
praised for bringing awareness to the
Polynesian culture but we also love to
step up in animation details for example
the one his hair was done using brand
new tools that made it look completely
realistic and unique the color of Moana
clothing was chosen based on historical
and regional accuracy and the designer
only used materials that would actually
be available um blue on his Island at
the time pretty cool right but not as
cool as this modern-day Moana he's
definitely ready to rebel and do things
her own way and that's it for our video
for more Disney videos check out 10
Disney Princesses reimagined as parents
see you next time
[Music]